while the president said he is well
prepared to meet with Kim Jong moon on
Tuesday he also said attitude is more
important than preparation then Tracy is
in Singapore looking ahead to the
much-anticipated meeting their been good
morning good morning so we just arrived
here in Singapore a couple of hours ago
and there's definitely a buzz in the air
about this upcoming summit it's unclear
if people are more excited about the
idea perhaps catching a glimpse of
president Trump or of Kim Jong moon now
as for the summit itself these two
leaders have a pretty big gap to close
in their negotiation president Trump
continues to say that his goal is to get
North Korea to agree to complete
denuclearization and also a quick
timeline for making that happen
but Kim Jong moon has only said he's
willing to talk about it and has made no
firm promises or said what he would want
in return for giving up his weapons now
on Thursday President Trump stated that
if North Korea does not agree to D nuke
than the harsh sanctions on the regime
would remain in place and he warned that
if the meeting here on Tuesday is not
going well he will simply walk out of it
but the president continues to predict
that he thinks this will be a successful
summit here in Singapore he says if he
and Kim jong-un hit it off he will
invite him to visit the United States
Alex then Tracy and Singapore thanks Ben
we will bring you live extensive
coverage of the summit CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor will be in Singapore on
Monday to lead our reporting right here
on CBS this morning